this is actually this actually completes
me
because had i not been in the streets
for this period of time i would have
been incomplete
all right montgomery
montgomery where'd you grow up where are
you from originally oh i'm from i was
born in guyana in south america and i
grew up in brooklyn oh is that right yes
and tell me about your family growing up
you had both your parents
well initially i had both my parents in
a house and uh we grew up as a family
but then my parents left left and came
to the united states so
then i was with my older sisters
but we had some problems then
this was in in guyana in guyana yeah i
was about eight or nine years old
what kind of things are going on well
you know
i was
very smart as a kid so
if we had a conversation and i was a kid
you tell me once if you if you tell me
twice i'd say why are you telling me
that again i'm not done
you don't think i heard you the first
time i don't remember so i was a little
smart from that time so when the parents
left
to me
i had some problems with the siblings
the older siblings so i moved out in the
yard and started we had a little we had
our own home we had built two stories so
we had a little
coop in the yard where we kept falls and
chickens and stuff so i moved into there
and i started living in there meanwhile
i was supposed to be in school
because we were getting ready in the
british system we were getting ready for
this common entrance exam which takes
you to a high school
so while i was in there and living for a
while
my
father's brother and sisters they got
wind of it all the children said hey we
can't control this guy come and get him
so they came looking for me well
i was one of the fastest runners in the
area in my class in school
and so uh
he hired three of the local boys and
they chased me all night through the
woods and threw all through the whole
city they didn't catch me but guess what
in the morning i had to go back and go
to sleep so i went back in the fall went
to sleep
so when i went to sleep he was across
the street talking to the chinese guy
who lived across the street so yeah he's
he sleeps in that tent over there so
they came and got me and took me to his
parents his sister's house in a
different part of the country
but so i i don't know i guess it was a
smart way of being connected to siblings
to the other generation for information
did you finish school oh yeah
because uh
from there i took the exam
and i got
entrance into one of the private high
schools and that's where i went to high
school
and eventually you came to brooklyn uh
after that i went to three of the
british forms
in the form system
and then from there i came to the united
states i came to brooklyn
and then i went to high school
so i finished high school when i was
about 16.
but uh like i said i was a smart kid so
uh
some people might call it rude
um
yeah i finished high school
when i got up over here being separated
from the rest of my family because i was
the only one back there going to school
i came and they meshed this together it
didn't it wasn't happening
so
you know
i would say i would let's say for
example let's say i want to go to the
park
he says okay go find go to park and says
we had some other friends i want to go
to this friend's house
so one time i went to the park instead
of going to i went to the friend's house
instead of going to the park because he
won't let me go to the friend's house
and i said look look pops this is not
going to work i'm not going to lie to
you
i'm not going to tell you i'll go go
here and then go there
so i just won't tell you where i'm going
and so we had that confrontation and uh
you know
from the age of 13 i began to plan my
life
by myself
and
i said i wanted some military experience
and i wanted a few other things
and so from 13 to 18 i planned where i
would i planned my whole life
and then my brother went was in germany
and my older brother was in germany in
the army and he came back home he says
what is this i hear you're a man in this
house
you're doing whatever you want
well you can't do that here if you're
going to be a man you're going to have
to find your own place so immediately
upon my 18th birthday i moved out and i
moved into my own apartment
how'd you support yourself huh how did
you support yourself i was working i
found jobs even though i was 16 i
graduated from high school i was working
since i was 16. i was i was actually my
first job was a messenger clerk on the
new york stock exchange
for bankers trust company
so i was carrying a whole lot of uh
securities i was bonded at the time
[Music]
so i had money coming in all the time
where'd your life go from there
uh well i tried that i tried a few
colleges i played soccer so i played for
saint francis i played for another
community college
and then uh i just joined the military
you know because i wanted some military
experience and so after i joined the
military you know i drank a little bit
here and there and i drank a little and
so you know i was drinking in the
military but i had a good career in the
military
how many years were you there i was i
was in the marines for eight years
yeah
it's a great job a high level of
professionalism
uh great friends
um
strange places get to meet a lot of
people
you know
a lot of interesting things happen you
know you never laugh as
hard and your drinking continued
uh just in the service and then
afterwards yes
tell me about that
well
deployment is is something where you
know you you deploy and what else is
there to do you go and you play you play
a few sports and then
you go to work in the day and when you
get off you hit the bars
and as you hit the bars then you come
back and you know it's a routine every
day
so that becomes a little
draining you know habitual after a while
it's
beer women beer women
work you know in the marines we work
hard and we play hard that's just the
way it is
and you uh you eventually came to l.a
uh
what happened is
i was living in orange county and i had
i had a son with a woman and we were
living in a place and i had some
problems with her
and uh
my life began to spiral out of control
and so uh
me and the two of us weren't getting
along
and so i left
you know rather than having it to become
an abusive situation i walked out of
situation
and uh i began to i i
came on this journey where i ended up
homeless i've been homeless for a long
time
how many years
uh since 2000 about 2002
wow
20 years
pretty much
a lot of it on skate row
uh i've
been to a lot of the homeless places in
a lot of different cities
i've been able to learn a lot of things
from it i was in new york i went to
atlanta
i came here i did some time in portland
just moved around to a few alcohol is
your is your drug it's my it's my drink
of choice
i still drink today yes
what do you prefer
uh wine wine
and you where do you stay if you're
homeless you're
ah over the years i've stayed at a whole
lot of different places here on skid row
you know
i had some
i tried the va it didn't work
certain other programs just you know
like like a lot of other things i
once you're a smart kid and you're smart
growing up you get bored easily
and so you know like if i would get a
job
i would train the people to do what i
knew
and then i have no further interest in
that you know i go find another one
where i learn something
and so
you know it's it's
and the marine corps teaches you gives
gives you a habit of a standard that
doesn't fit in in many other places
so you you kind of go from place to
place
and your
your drinking typically
takes you where
during the day
or night
um
how bad does it get it i guess that's
what i'm asking uh well it got worse
really bad when i was overseas when i
was in the service i mean i i would
drink and uh
i i got up one day and
there was something in the sink you know
these cultures are different than ours i
walked in the sink
there was some poop in the stink
and i was like did i do that
not even knowing if i had done it or not
you know what i mean and then so i kind
of was embarrassed in the morning and i
got up and i was with a girl you know it
says this
is got a question for you you know you
just kind of you don't know how to ask
that question
you're like i said
there's some because she was a small
girl so their toilets are outside so she
probably didn't want to go outside in
the middle of night i don't know how
this worked but she shouldn't sing
so i'm like did i do that
and she said oh no no you didn't do that
that was me and so then you know
but you know i mean
that's what we do as friends yeah
i guess we party and we drink we work
hard and we play hard
and you're so how do you support
yourself now
i'm on gr
i'm trying to make a few things happen
for myself right now and uh
well who knows
we'll see what happens but you know you
you seem very smart
well that's you know that's that's that
was the problem in the beginning you're
homeless and
drinking
on skid row so it's not about smarts is
it um
there are some people that
they have
smartness doesn't mean
an eloquence it doesn't mean it just
means that you have certain abilities
it doesn't mean that you will avoid
certain situations actually it works
still sometimes to your detriment
because
yeah it's intimidating to other people
intelligence can put you here exactly
exactly exactly exactly and plus
you know they're blockages
that's what i call them they're
blockages and i
instead of going through i go around
if you understand what i'm saying
because
i may not have the solution to that
blockage right there and then
so there's a chance to learn certain
other things and rather than beating my
head against the blockage
and you have you have children
um i've had some situations that have to
be clarified that have to be worked out
and how do you know
i'm 61.
20 years have gone by real fast
do you see any way out
i hope so alcohol is a hard drug to put
down
but a lot of people do it
also smart isn't hard it's a hard drug
get by it it takes wisdom to to to be
able to maneuver
through any obstacle in life even if
it's alcoholism or
being too smart
and so um
but there are ways around everything
maybe maybe your intelligence will
figure out a way out
my belief
it's based on what i believe if i
believe there's a way out
i'll find one there's a way out
whether you want to
go through
that gauntlet is the question
well the road many have chosen is not
the is not always the same
and so i can't say that um what worked
for johnny would work for me yeah for
sure or what works for me would work for
dom you got to find your own way
and and my experience it my path will be
based on my experiences
taking all of that together
you know
you've tried a.a
i have been to several ae meetings what
do you think i've been to an a meeting i
think they're excellent programs
i enjoy them
i never fully completed a course but
i've been to the
well you know this is just another
school for me
the years that i've spent amongst the
homeless population because there's
information i can learn here that is
most invaluable that i can't learn
anyplace else
you know
the military there's information i
learned there that is invaluable
you you understand and the the
information you learn here
is precious
but it's more politically driven it's
it's more like the political end of
things
the most most people see the streets as
a depository for losers
well i see it for me
as an entrance into the political arena
because
it's not that you're soft
but this is where
or or even in entertainment this is
where if someone slap you
you're not interested in slapping them
back because they want to make money
they want to sue you
you understand and so
this is where you learn to take a punch
the streets yeah because they will punch
at you
they will punch you
you understand and if you
if you want to punch back you better
find different means of fighting
you see in the military it's different
you shoot at me i'll shoot back at you
and i'll use my tactics to get around
you out here
it's a different set of tactics it's a
different set of skills that are in
place that you have to use
to be able to survive the streets as you
notice what's happening out there right
now there's a lot of people dying
because they haven't mastered the
tactics of survival that is required
to stay alive in the streets
because you can you can od in the
streets and even so you don't have to go
deep because you do drugs people can
drug you
while you sleep
and do things to you that you don't
normally have done and i believe i've
had some of those experiences
that you know okay if you're going to
accuse me of that you'll have to prove
it
i've had some of those characters that
i've had to deal with in my private life
as well as in the streets
so you know
but i i i i'm actually pleased with my
level of knowledge
what is combined from
the military to the streets because
this is actually this actually completes
me
because had i not been in the streets
for this period of time i would have
been incomplete
but my sister looked at me one day and
she said
when my one one of my uncles died she
said
what happened to you
she said you used to be so brilliant as
a child what happened
i told her i was more brilliant now than
i was then but she couldn't look at me
and tell that's the way it is
because of course you know
and then i had another incident my mom i
go home from my dad's funeral
and my mom looks at me and she says son
[Music]
what happened
she said you should you should have been
some great big lawyer some big time
doctor what happened
what happened to you
i didn't have an answer for my mom
well i just hope to make her proud one
day
even though she's no longer here but i
love my mom you see i could always
relate to my mom one day i brought a
girl home
and my mom started questioning her i was
that was about 13.
and i said hours maybe i was 16. i said
hey mom wait i said you got five dollars
i said you go make sure that their lives
are perfect
before you come asking this girl
my mom just left her alone went on about
her business
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
you know in these 20 years i learned
i learned a tremendous amount of stuff
and a lot of
and it it it is the ability to have to
to discern and understand knowledge
to know that i learned
certain things here
i learned certain things in being
homeless
and these things i learned here i would
never learn that i've been here
and so i'd say they're most both areas
are invaluable
but this this area in homelessness is
treasured
yeah i've heard that before from quite a
few people it's treasured it's treasured
you it can't it cannot be bought and
paid for at a university
there are experiences in human relations
that you learn here that you would never
learn anywhere else
all right montgomery thank you so much
for sharing your story oh
thank you so much for inviting me to uh
share i wish you the best of luck i hope
you your intelligence gets you wherever
you want to go
and wisdom yeah
all right thank you mark thank you
you